[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Rob and welcome
to my tutorial for thee in my last video
over 570 people voted in less than a day
and 96% of people said yes they wanted
to see the origami kaleidoscope so I'm
going to show you how to make this today
it's a really awesome model that gets
its name from a real kaleidoscope that
does something like this we okay
I'm dizzy now it requires seven modular
units that look just like this now what
is able to work without tape however I
found that after a while it does
eventually pop out so I wound up
applying a little bit of tape just to
hold everything together I'm going to be
using seven sheets of eight-and-a-half
by eleven printer paper for blue and
three red however you can use any kind
of paper that you want if you want to
use seven pieces of origami paper or you
can use two sheets and I'll show you how
to split them up into quarters so that
you can get something smaller just like
this once you have the paper you want to
use you're ready to go depending on
whether you want to make this small
kaleidoscope or the big kaleidoscope
will determine how you need to rip the
paper if you want to make the small one
we're going to first get the square out
of the printer paper and then we're
going to split it into quarters for the
big one we just need to take the paper
and then make it into a square by
folding the top edge over to the side
edge and tearing off the bottom so let's
go ahead and do that so I did the same
with one of the red printer sheets to
get three more of these squares and I
did the same with six printer sheets
over here to get six more of these
squares because the kaleidoscope is a
modular origami model I'm going to show
you how to make one of them and then the
rest of the six you're going to make on
your own because they are exactly the
same I'm going to use the big pieces of
paper but it works the exact same way
with the smaller pieces of paper so
let's get started now we have a piece of
paper that has a diagonal fold going
this way we're going to take the upper
left corner and fold it down to the
bottom right corner line up the edges
and make a crease along the edge again
we need to be really neat so just run
your fingernail against
edge to make sure it's nice and sharp
then you can open it up and you'll see
we have an X we're going to take all
four of the corners here and fold it
directly into the middle just like this
make a crease along the edge and do the
same with the remaining three
and once again don't forget to crease
your fingernail against the edges here
now you can open up all four of the
corners and you'll see we have a cross
and then we have a little bit of a box
here we're going to flip the paper over
now I'm going to take the top edge and
fold it down to the bottom line up the
edges and make a nice sharp crease open
up the paper and we're going to fold the
top edge and the bottom edge directly on
to this horizontal crease here now when
you unfold the edges you'll see we now
split the paper into quarters so your
paper should look something like this
we're now going to take the paper and
fold it in half on the horizontal fold
just like this and we're basically going
to make the waterbomb base in order to
do that just hold it on the left side of
this diagonal fold like this open up
these two flaps and we're going to fold
it along this back diagonal fold and
this front diagonal fold so just open up
the side of the paper and push on this
top edge here at the same time we want
to fold on this diagonal crease and the
back one just like that as you can see
the paper is kind of already creased on
those folds so it's not that hard to
kind of get it to close just like that
okay so we just tuck this edge in and we
flattened out the paper do the same with
the other side open it up push all the
way up to this top point so you might
need to just untuck the paper if it gets
a little wrinkled fold it on the front
crease and on the back one and tuck in
the middle of the paper so that you have
two flaps on the Left flatten out the
paper and now we've basically made a
waterbomb base so we're just going to
flip it over like this and we're going
to crease the front of the paper on this
horizontal fold right here take the top
edge and pull it down along this crease
just like that hold your thumbs in the
middle here and just gently press on
that horizontal fold all the way to the
edges here now
as you can see we have a crease here and
a crease here we're going to fold
upwards on those to create valley folds
so just push here like this
and do the same with the left side so
there's pushed on this little triangle
and flatten it out and as you'll see now
we have an upside down house so we're
gonna do that with the other side flip
it over pull down on this on the
horizontal crease put your thumbs inside
and press all the way to the edge now we
can fold upwards on this little V here
okay so just push up like that increase
and push up like that and crease so now
you see we'll have something that looks
almost like an upside down house okay
we're going to open it up here now and
do the same thing that we did with the
waterbomb base the inside reverse-fold
open it up and just push like that so
that you have a little bit of a flap
okay we have a little flap here do the
same with the other three open it up
push and flatten it out flip it over
open push open push and flatten it out
now we could flatten the whole thing out
and just make really good creases on
this edge here and all for the edges so
now you've completed one of the modular
units and it should look just like this
once your paper looks just like mine we
need to make six more of the modular
units so take your remaining six sheets
and make six more so now you should have
seven modular units and you're ready to
join them up to create the origami
infinity kaleidoscope okay so to make
the kaleidoscope I'm going to start out
with just two units and I'm going to set
the rest of them aside
if you pick up two of the units and you
open up the one on the left you'll see
in the middle we have an X right there
okay I'm just gonna make a dot so you
can see it and the one on the right we
have a point right on the end here
to join the two units we need to put
this point right in the middle here so
if you open up the pieces and you slide
it so that this edge of the paper is
directly in the middle of the piece on
the left you'll see that they'll
actually slide right in because the
folds are identical so you just need to
slip it in here like this so that these
two points line up and make sure that
the folds overlap now all we need to do
is to just flatten everything out just
like that so it might be a little tricky
at first but you'll see once you flatten
it out all the fold should be overlapped
now we're going to do the same thing
with another unit take a blue one now or
whatever color you're using open it up a
little bit not too much and this point
here is going to go in the middle of the
red one right here so again just kind of
slide it in here like this and open up
this flap and line up the creases so
line up this one and this one just like
that
now we could just flatten it out again
so now you should have something like
this and then we're going to take
another red unit and the same thing so
we're just gonna take the point and put
it in the middle of the paper line up
the folds and flatten everything out
flatten it and then grab another unit
and do the same exact thing point in the
middle and line up the creases flatten
it out take another red unit put the
point directly in the middle of the blue
one and again flatten all the creases
now we're ready to do the last unit it
works the same way take the point and
put it in the middle of the red unit and
flatten everything out so now you should
have all seven modular units connected
and we are ready to join them up
together at this point you should have
something that looks just like this so
when you flip it over you should have
alternating colors if you use two
different colors and you'll see this is
the first unit that I started with
because there's a little black point
down there
okay this is the last unit I just added
what we're going to do is we're going to
rotate everything like this and bring
the two last units end units together
this is the list when I just added this
one is going to go into the middle of
the first unit so just open up the first
unit just like that and this is the
middle right there where I made that
little dot so it's a little bit tricky
but with the bigger units is not as hard
so we're just going to basically put
this point right here in the middle so
it's a little tricky at first but we're
just gonna put it just like that okay
right in there and in like that there we
go
I got it in alright now I just need to
make sure all of the creases are really
sharp okay so this is the last unit
right here I'm gonna close it and just
crease along the edge here and right
here where I just added it because we
can't really flatten it out anymore
all right so you're just gonna pinch it
right here where we just added all right
just make sure all of the units are
really lined up and you've come
cleated the origami infinity
kaleidoscope now you'll see it will work
without tape however eventually I found
that it'll pop out or get stuck so what
I like to do is put a little bit of tape
right on the edges here so I'm gonna go
ahead and do that so it looks something
like this as you'll see I put a little
tape here and here and all throughout
the rest of the kaleidoscope so just
take a small amount of tape maybe like
that long okay like the width of your
pinky tear it and we're gonna put a
little bit right here and fold it over
[Music]
okay again if you want to just ensure
that all these creases are nice and
sharp what I like to do is just pinch
them like this and like this and just
crease along the edges now to get it to
work what you're going to do is you're
going to put your thumbs on the inside
here and your pointers and fingers on
the other side now all of the bottom
points need to touch in order to get it
to flip inside-out so watch ready this
is it flipping inside-out okay all the
bottom points are touching and that's
one now on the bottom here again all the
bottom points are touching and I open it
like that okay
so that's two different configurations
now this is the hardest one to kind of
get to go inside out so you kind of
gotta bring everything together like
this and you can kind of flip it all
right just like that and that's all the
different configurations so you just got
to go along with it and practice it and
you'll see you'll be able to get it to
flip now if it does get stuck like this
see how that got stuck what you're gonna
have to do is just basically bring it to
the center like that and put it back in
if if worse comes to worst you need to
open it up and just flatten everything
out again and interlock them again but
honestly I've never really had to do
that I just kind of fix it like that
okay so again just just turning it
inside out by taking your fingers and
pushing in the middle here on all the
points and opening it up like a flower
almost and there you go there is your
origami infinity kaleidoscope definitely
one of my most favorite models now thank
you guys so much for watching my video
for the origami infinity
kaleidoscope I hope you've really
enjoyed it like I do if you did like it
be sure to leave a like down below by
pressing the thumbs up button it really
helps me out and also don't forget to
subscribe by clicking the little button
somewhere around here or also down below
and click the notification bell so you
get all notifications from my channel so
what do you guys want to see next I'm
gonna flash some stuff on the screen so
you might have to pause it the ninja
star cube the flapping dragon the mini
flick football or maybe some easy dollar
magic leave me a comment down below let
me know and also don't forget to vote in
the poll and again thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time